[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم في 29 نوفمبر
الجاري 2022 والعده ايام سيلتقي الجانبين
الامريكي والروسي على اراضي مصريه لمناقشه
تفعيل واحده من اهم معاهدات الحد من
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه بين الدولتين
الاكبر نوويه في العالم وهي نيو ستارت
مادام بنتكلم على نيو ستارت لازم كان فيه
اولد ستارت ولازم في خلفيه للمعاهدات اللي
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد السوفيتي سابقا
ثم روسيا لاحقا
انخرطوا فيها من وقت المبكر وده موضوع
حلقتنا النهارده
المعاهدات اللي همم التزمت بها الدولتين
الاكبر للحد من انتشار الاسلحه النوويه
وتحديدا نيو ستارت وليه سبب الاهتمام
الكبير بها هذه الايام وطبعا بنستضيف خبير
ماء الدكتور يسري ابو شادي ليه يح نعم
تفاصيل كل هذه المعاهده مساء الخير معانا
الدكتور مساء النور اهلا وسهلا باختصار
شديد جدا احنا عارفين ان في مجموعه من
المعاهدات اللي وقعتها الولايات المتحده
وروسيا هدفها الحد من عدد الرؤوس النوويه
بين الدولتين الاكبر في العالم
وان نيو ستار دي اللي بيتفاوضوا على
تفعيلها مجددا اخر هذه المعاهدات هل ممكن
تدينا ملخص سريع جدا تاريخيا عن المعاهدات
اللي انخرطت فيها البلدين من حوالي 50 سنه
تمام يعني اولى بدايه اصلا سنه 45 لما
الولايات المتحده بدات في انتاج اول قنبله
ذريه وبدات بعد كده تنتج اعداد همم
متتاليه من هذه القناه بالاذاريه ال- همم
الروس حسوا بالقلق طبعا وفي سنه 49 فجروا
اول قنبله لهم وابتدوا كمان في سباق تسلح
نووي على المدى الخمسينات والستينات صوره
متزايده جدا لدرجه انه وصلوا لالاف مؤلفه
وصلت اقصاها في سنه 87 الى ما يخرج من
80,000 سلاح هو في العالم كله في العالم
كله ولكن اساسا طبعا العالم كله معناه
الروس والامريكان تمام جاء في سنه 72 واول
اتفاقيه للحد من التصالح النووي كان اسمها
صوت وان همم وقعت همم من قبل همم الرئيس
السيسي وايه كان غرض منها اساسا ومعظم
الاتفاقات اللي تمت بعد كده هي الحد من
الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه النوويه وهمم وفي
همم سنه 91 همم وقعتفاقيه هامه جدا اللي
هي سموها همم ستارت ودائما ستار يعني
استراتيجك رضاكشن همم تريتي ودي ال-
اتفاقيه دي همم همم
بعد وعطت سنه 94 وبدات تنفذه من 94 ونجعها
حقائق نجاح بالغ لان تقريبا 80% من
الاسلحه النوويه زي ما قلت ال 80,000 دول
همم شالت 80% من هذه الاسلحه وازالتها
تحولت الى فاضل يمكن حوالي 15,000 ولا
حاجه زي كده همم بدات تيجي اتفاقيات ثانيه
ستارتي توم يعني ما عملتش كثير قوي لكن
برده صارت السرير برده ما نجحتش ما تمش
الاتفاق عليها لحد ما جاء في 2011 همم
بايدن همم عرض الحقيقه اهو وبابا عربي
الاتفاق على الروس وكان الرئيس الروسي
وقتها اه دول عملوا الاتفاق اللي سموه
ستارت او معاهده ستارت واسترد على فكره مش
معناها ستارت معناها خرافيه اه اه
برده تركيز كله على الانواع اللي انا قلت
لكم عليها واحيانا كان بيركز على وسائل
نقل القنابل الذريه دي عن طريق الصواريخ
البالستيه او غيرها المهم انه هذا الاتفاق
اتوافق عليه في 2011 الكونجرس وافق عليه
برلمان الروسي يوافق عليه وبدا تنفيذه
كانت لمده 10 سنين اتفاق ده كان بيتضمن
ايه ال ال القضاء مش مش رضاكشن قوي
للاسلحه ناويه لان هي الاسلحه النوويه
كانت نزلت كثير نسبيه لما قلت لكم من
80,000 ليه 14,000 لكن للتاكد ان هذا
الاسلحه ده هي مزادتش وبالتالي الاتفاق ده
كان فيه بنود في غايه الاهميه وبنود قويه
جدا منها انه يتم التفتيش من كل بلد على
الثانيه 18 مره في السنه انه الخبراء بتاع
كل بلد بيروح يزول المواقع اللي بيطلع
الصواريخ النوويه دي هي واللي فيها
كازي من الاسلحه النوويه وهمم لك في نفس
الوقت
هما شكله لجنه همم لدراسه تنفيذ هذه
الاتفاقيه اللجنه دي مسؤوله عن تبادل
المعلومات كل فتره زمنيه بصوره خاصه كل
سنه لازم كل واحد يتكلم على التوتال بتاعه
الانفنتوري بتاعته فيها قد ايه وعنده
صواريخ ايه انواعها ايه يتبادلوا
المعلومات بينهم وبين بعض
نجحت في البدايات وكان ماشيه كويس قوي لحد
ما جاءت ترامب ايه مكانه عجباك اتفاقيه زي
ما عجبتهوش حاجات ثانيه كثير لكن هو ما
انسحابش زي ايران ايران بشكل واضح وهو ليه
ما انسحبش لانه قال لك ايه هتخلص في خلال
عشره سنين يعني 2011 201
وقتها بزيارات تاجلت لكن واقع 10 سنين
قربوا يخلصوا لكن بايظن تحمس الحقيقه الى
مد الاتفاق خمس سنين يعوض عن الفتره اللي
حصل فيها توقف
والكونجرس وافق على الخمس سنين البرلمان
الروسي وافق وتم توقيع اتفاقيه هتنتهي يوم
اربعه فبراير
2026 اذا قدامهم بقى دلوقت لسه بتاع اربع
خمس سنين على ما يخلص طيب يعني عايزين
نرجع ثاني النظام زي ما كان ماشي
الطريق تطبيق الاتفاقيه دي وقت اتفاقيه
مهمه للطرفين همم لازم تنفس طيب نعمل ايه
يبقى اللجنه اللي هي مسؤوله عن تطبيق لازم
تجتمع برئاسه على مستوى عالي قد تكون وزير
الدفاع في البلدين ويختاروا حقيقه مصر
يمكن الاسباب متعدده همم لان هتكون هي
المقر الاجتماعي اللي هينقشوا فيه التنفيذ
اللي فات والتنفيذ الحالي
المتعلق بهذه الاتفاقيه هي اتفاقيه مهمه
للغايه مؤكد طبعا قد يصار وان كان الموضوع
بس سياسي شويه ال- اا بعض التهديدات
الروسيه بشان الحرب الاوكرانيه واحتمالات
استخدام فطبعا هنا هيبقى فيه نوع من
المناقشه قد تدخل فيها بعض السياسه لكن
الاجتماع اساسا اجتماع فني
لاسلحه النوويه اذا اللي احنا هنشوفه خلال
الايام اللي جايه ولا الاعلام هيتكلم عليه
هو ان الجانب الروسي والجانب الامريكي
موجودين على الاراضي المصريه
للتفاوض لتفعيل الاتفاق اللي هو نيو ستارت
اللي تم ماته بالفعل لخمس سنوات يعني
لغايه 2000 26 اعتقد اربعه فبراير 2016 24
وتفعيلها بشكل جدي بعد ما تم تجميدها
لاسباب المتعدده سواء لعدم قناعه الرئيس
ترامب وفقا للدكتور ابو شادي او بسبب يعني
التوتر ما بين بعدين واللي همم سهمت فيه
كمان كعامل لتبطيء الزيارات ما بين الجانب
الروسي والجانب الامريكي اللي هي طبعا
اندلاع كورونا اا هذا هو الهدف من هذه
المفاوضات واذكركم انه اليوسفرت كلها هي
امتداد الى ستارت وان الواقعه في مطلع
التسعينات وهدفها الحد من الرؤوس النبويه
اللي تكدست تحديدا في روسيا والولايات
المتحده ووصلت لحدها الاقصى سنه 87 عند ال
80,000 راس نووي موزعه طبعا على اكثر من
دوله لكن ميللي او بشكل رئيسي روسيا
والولايات المتحده انا اعتقد ان هم ده
يعني فضلوا اللقاء على الارض المصريه في
تقديري انا من متابعته المتواضعه انه كان
عاده لما روسيا والولايات المتحده بيقرروا
اللقاء بيلتقوا على بلد المحايد كانت
تقليديه بيفضلوا اللقاء في فنلندا او في
السويد باعتبار ان هم كانوا دولتين محاينت
او سويسرا
في لندن والسويد تقدموا بطلب همم عضويه
لحلف شمال الاطلسي ففقدوا صفه محايد
بالنسبه لسويسرا هي صحيح ما زالت تحتفظ
نفسها بوضع محايد لكن مع التوتر ما بين
الغرب يعني وروسيا سويسرا كانت موقفها
اقرب الى همم المعسكر الغربي وبالتالي
يبدو ان هم كانوا بيبحثوا عن دوله بتلعب
دور محايد لا مع هذا ولا مع ذلك وبالتالي
اختاره مصر ده في تقديري انا وربما تكون
هناك اسباب اخرى هنكتشفها مع مرور الوقت
ناموا الخير يا معلم الدكتور ان المفاوضات
ديت تنجح وبالتالي تجرفنا عن فكره السباق
النووي اللي هو فيها اشاره جميله قوي
الحقيقه لمصر لانها تستضيف همم لقاء حساس
زي ده طيب همم ميعاد الدكتور سؤال الاخير
هل همم تعتقد انه اذا نجح همم تفعيل هذا
الاتفاق ده ممكن يعني عاكس على تهد
يعني الاجواء اللي هي كلها ملبده بالغيوم
والتهديدات النوويه ولا ده ملوش علاقه جدا
لان الاتفاق ده بيطلب زي ما قلت 18 زياره
للمفتشين طب لما انا اسمح لو انا سمحت
فعلا ان ال 18 زياره تتم مؤكد الامريكان
والروس كل واحد يختار المواقع الحساسه
اللي هو درسها بالستالايت وبكل حاجه عشان
يتاكد انه لا ده هو مغيرش ده هو درجه
استعداده ايه مؤكد ده هيؤدي الى نوع من
الاقلال من الشقوق اللي موجوده عند
الطرفين ونتمنى يعني
الشكوك دي تقل قوي عشان ما حدش يغلط لكن
محتاجه من الطرفين يحسبوها بدقه شويه قبل
التهديدات دي يعني او بتستخدام السلاح
النوويه ههه
كفايه 1,000 راس ناوي عشان يدمرونا
ويدمروا ويدمروا العالم ده ده حقيقي جدا
وده اللي ب- دول العالم كله بالطالبه لكن
تدريجي انا اعتقد الناس دي هتوصل قناع
الضغط الشعبي في العالم كله هيوصل على
الضغط على حكوماتهم وبصوره خاصه همم روسيا
والولايات المتحده انهي سلاح النووي ده
تماما
شكرا جزيلا على الدكتور